Скандальний міністр закордонних справ Польщі Вітольд Ващиковський,
який заявляв що Україна не увійде до Європи з Бандерою,
позбувся своєї посади.
Прем’єр-міністр країни Матеуш Моравецький
провів ревізію уряду і звільнив чільників одразу дев'яти міністерств,
призначивши на їхні місця нових.
Але Україні від цих урядових переформатувань
не слід очікувати якогось поліпшення відносин з Польщею.
Міняються лише урядовці, а Кабміном продовжує негласно керувати Ярослав Качинський
та його правоконсервативна партія "Право і справедливість",
вважає експерт Богдан Яременко з Майдану закордонних справ.
Їхня політика спричинила кризу не лише у стосунках з Україною,
але й з Європейським Союзом.
Перестановка міністрів у польському уряді зумовлена насамперед
внутрішьополітичними цілями уряду.
На думку експертів, максимум на що можна очікувати
від зокрема, нового міністра закордонних справ Польщі Яцека Чапутовіча,
це незначного пом’якшення риторики на адресу України.
Консервативна правляча партія Польщі розігрує історичну карту
для консолідації свого електорату,
тому різка риторика на адресу України вигідна нинішній владі в Польщі,
впевнений член громадської ради при МЗС України Андрій Бузаров.
Реальні зміни в українсько-польських відносинах можуть відбутися
лише за зміни влади у Польщі і перемоги лібералів.
Відносини між Україною і Польщею 2017 року опинилися на дні через історичні питання.
Польська влада знову і знову порушує темуВолинськоїтрагедії
1943-го року,
під час якої загинули десятки тисяч поляків і українців.
У 2016-му Сенат Польщі
без узгодження з Групою українсько-польського діалогу
виніс це питання на порядок денний
і визнав волинські події геноцидом поляків.